Facebook's Cambridge analytic a scandal
is fueling the debate over how to
protect digital information one hacker
from Texas is also raising awareness
about growing cyber threats and he's
only 12 years old
Ruben Paul is a 6th grader from Austin
he hacks household items to demonstrate
how they can be exploited to spy on or
even harm people David Pegg no recently
met the self-proclaimed cyber ninja who
showed him how smart toys can be turned
into listening devices hi everybody
Ruben Paul is 12 years old and he's
helping to lead the conversation on
cybersecurity presenting in the
Netherlands advising a tech conference
in Singapore and wowing a crowd full of
executives in Texas it was important
that we need to reinvent cybersecurity
because obviously what we have invented
so far is clearly not working this cyber
ninja as he calls himself has a second
degree black belt in Kung Fu and he's on
a mission to show how hacking is child's
play 12 year old can do it what makes it
that somebody is a skilled actual cyber
terrorist what what makes it that they
can't do it this Bluetooth is going into
new autonomous cars autonomous drones
it's going into medical devices Paul
says that the Bluetooth and Wi-Fi
connections that we use almost every day
are extremely vulnerable to hacking
I'll never connect to a public Wi-Fi
that I don't know really somebody can
just hack into that Wi-Fi network and
poison it he showed me firsthand how a
hackers poison can spread from a Wi-Fi
signal I successfully know your password
how you know what that I've hacked you
you're logging ones so call me gullible
you got me it took seconds he had my
Twitter username and password using a
fake page that he'd cloned after I
connected to his public Wi-Fi network
it's that easy mm-hmm so in other words
if I was sitting at a Starbucks
I went to sign in to Twitter I put it in
they got it now staying in touch is easy
and fun Paul also hacked cloud pets
teddy bear it uses Bluetooth technology
allowing traveling parents to send
messages back to their kids what did you
do that turns that into a threat without
any notification or any knowledge of the
user I could turn it on from my computer
which only has to be in a 30 foot radius
of the bear so I could stand outside
someone's Restless he turned the bear
into a secret recording device who's the
smartest one in the family the Paul
family of four is hopeful about the
future of cybersecurity
Ruben's parents mano and Sangeeta both
work in technology and his six-year-old
brother etai is even joining him on
stage now can you show us this sure ask
when they shine at it and liking what
they do it gives you a feeling of
contentment with Ruben speaking at these
conferences and being paid thousands of
dollars to travel there and sometimes a
speaker's fee do you worry that it gets
a little out of control for a 12 year
old cousin for most the kids do it
because they have a passion for it right
it should never become a job for them so
if tomorrow they come back and they say
not interested in doing this it's
perfectly fine with my wife and I Ruben
says in the future he wants to work for
the NSA or the FBI protecting the
country against foreign and domestic
cyber threats has anyone called you I
feel like they should be recruiting you
now I've had some offers from the
government of the Netherlands and even
the Department of Defense did you tell
them what I got to graduate for yeah I
want to get sixth grade first before
they start thinking that job for CBS
this morning I'm David beg No and a
child shall lead them we reached out to
cloud pets and spiralled toys the
companies behind the teddy bear that
Paul hacked neither responded to our
requests for comment on its
when website cloud pets says users
acknowledge the company may capture
audio recordings and that it may use or
store the recordings and the data
contained within them Paul set up a
non-profit to create videos that teach
people about cyber dangers he hopes to
one day study at Caltech or MIT and he
also aspires to be an Olympic gymnast
that is he guy well the NSA may be a
phone call away for him so right that
rare NSA Olympic gymnast double-major
you never know